âgés de 5 à 13 ans ses enfants
apprivoise le monde du cirque équilibre
sur le fil et chasse mais aussi
acrobaties sur la boule ou au sol j'ai
fait la boule on a fait le clown on a
fait les tiers 6 l on a fait la
galipette des contorsions étaient au
programme avec des noms pour chaque
figure c'est amer ce stage est organisé
par alexandra bouglione issu d'une
célèbre famille de cirque traditionnel
elle fait découvrir aux enfants son
univers
le stage de cirque nous le proposons
depuis sept ans maintenant depuis 2013
c'est un stage pluridisciplinaire de
cirque
on a adapté évidemment le stage à ce
contexte si particulier et en même temps
ça nous a permis de travailler de faire
d'autre notre apprentissage d'autres
techniques en groupe peut-être plus
restreints dans l'atelier installé dans
l'auditorium municipal les tables sont
espacées pour respecter la distance d'un
mètre et un lot de crayon est attribué à
chaque enfant
ils oeuvrent sur un dessin réalisé par
henri de toulouse lautrec tiré de
l'album au cirque chevaux en liberté
nous ici l'objectif c'est plutôt 2
s'inscrit dans la complémentarité de
proposer une approche du cirque qui va
plus être axée sur sur l'art et
notamment l'histoire de l'art vingt
enfants participent à ces ateliers
encadrés notamment par vladik après une
carrière dont le cirque il a décidé
d'enseigner les enfants choisissez dans
votre tête
quel quel petit de saynètes vous voulez
faire
diatou quoi dans le circuit à l'émotion
il ya la prise de risque il ya le
dépassement de soi qu'est la solidarité
c'est vraiment une très bonne école et
des valeurs qui sont beaucoup rechercher
la vie moderne
le coût de cette semaine 180 euros par
enfant prochains stages durant les
vacances de la toussaint